den uns ein bisschen was passiert gerade
hinter den kulissen naja dort hat man
einige beschlüsse schon halbwegs
vorbereitet momentan reden sind noch
über diverse andere punkte die noch zu
klären sind was wir bislang wissen weil
der vorsicht bevor es dann verkündet
wird ist zum einem bußgeld das
bundesweit mindestens 50 euro betragen
soll für diejenigen die keine maske
tragen dass die verpflichtung gibt es
bundesweit inzwischen schon speziell
auch auf bahnhöfen sollte noch mal
geklärt werden es soll auch und das ist
vielleicht ein bisschen strittig geklärt
werden ob die polizei grundsätzlich
dieses bußgeld einziehen kann oder muss
oder ob das auch möglicherweise
angestellter der bahn sein können da
gibts noch ein bisschen diskussion in
jedem fall grund mindestbußgeld von 50
euro weil verstoß gegen die masken
mindestbußgeld heißt aber auch da wieder
bundesländer können es anders man
beispielsweise in bayern ist es ja schon
längst viel teurer wenn man jemand
bayern in berlin bekannt bis zu 500
gehen das wird ist offen gelassen
aber soweit zumindest aber da gibt es
noch ausnahmen nämlich sachsen anhalt
hat gesagt wir wollen das nicht
bei uns wird immer maske getragen sagte
reiner haselhoff der ministerpräsident
also brauchen wir das eigentlich nicht
darüber gab es ein bisschen zu oft hat
man sich darauf geeinigt dass kann das
land kann das selbst entscheiden das
ohnehin muss immer alles in den ländern
umgesetzt werden
also kann sachsen anhalt hier eine
ausnahme machen wenn ich einmal ganz
kurz da aber noch einen haken darf weil
der streit was gesagt ein bisschen
gestritten
wir haben da einen satz gehört den hass
läuft zur kanzlerin gesagt haben sonst
war
du bist kanzlerin und bis der deutschen
sprache noch mächtiger als ein einfacher
ministerpräsident wie kommt es überhaupt
dazu kommt so auf einmal miteinander
sprachen wird das war ja punkt zwei von
17 punkten
das heißt man war da ein bisschen
genervt sicherlich auf seiten der der
kanzlerin
denn sie hatte ihm vorher gesagt lieber
rainer die du zu sehen sind gleich alt
beide in der gleichen partei
rainer du bist doch der deutschen
sprache mächtig das steht da doch jetzt
ihr habt andrang an masken pflicht aber
in dem kein bußgeld ein und daraufhin
kamen dann die etwas schnippische
bemerkung von haseloff ja ja liebe
kanzlerin du bist halt noch viel
mächtiger weil du bist ja die große
kunst
das war deutlich ein bisschen genervt
die atmosphäre sagt uns auch jemand sein
nervige als sonst gewesen
so nervig wie lange nicht jedenfalls hat
ein teilnehmer mit aber erst sich damit
durchgesetzt also sein bruder alex vor
votum ist nicht das erste mal schon
einige male extra voten durchgeboxt kann
er auch er ist landeschef alle diese
verordnung müssen auf landesebene immer
noch mal umgesetzt werden